はーい、おはようございます
はい
おはようございます
はじめしゃちょーです
あれから、２ヶ月経ちました
色々すごいんだよね
そう
あれが３月だよ多分ね
３月に
店舗の
代表の権利を勝ち取って
早２ヶ月
えー、世界大会に繋がる
遊戯王の大会の
静岡の代表者が
決まります
静岡中の公認店舗の中から
代表者が３２人出てきて
その中で
上位３人が
日本大会に
出れるという訳です
今回代表として
で、僕ともう一人、後輩も一人
店舗代表になってるんで
ここ最近
遊戯王しかしてませんでした
今日の大会の会場は静岡じゃなくて
浜松なので
ちょっと今から遠出
してきます
今ほらレシピ晒すよ、世界に
ばかたれが
携帯使えないって言うから多分ダメ
人生ゲームのルールか
電卓と
メモ帳
買ってきます
よし、買ってきました
はい、という訳で
浜松に着きました
１時間前に来るっていうこの、
意識の固さ
高が遊戯王カードと思うんですけど
あれって対人だから
緊張するんだよね
なんか部活の試合並みに
会場に着いたんですけども
行った瞬間めちゃくちゃバレて
パニクったね
やばい
一回攻めずに時間があればね
外で待機してます
飯行こう
よっ！
いつも見てます！
本当？！
ありがとう
マジカヨwwwwww
マジカヨwwwwww　X２
テンションテンション...
受付２分前になりました
頑張ってきたよな
（遊戯王用語）
まあ
一勝できたのは
かなりデカかったと思います
静岡県の代表を決める大会で
まあ
二回戦敗退っていうことで
ま、けど、ま
静岡県ベスト..１６でございます
そう言ったら格好いいように聞こえるな
まあ１回戦も実はすごい時間掛かってて
１試合４０分なんですよ
で、３セットで
２本取ったら勝ちなんですけども
１回戦めの１セット目で
３５分掛かってて
もう多分その時点で僕はもう
集中力切れてて
まあ何とか延長戦まで入って
勝ったんですけども
２回戦までちょっと
頭が回んなくて
これで僕の今年の
遊戯王の世界に繋がる大会は
終..わりでござる
１年に１回しかないからね
実は結構
ゴリゴリに遊戯王やりまくってて
練習とかめちゃくちゃして
結構やったんですけども
まあ、ちょっとね、及ばずというか
動きもあまり良くなかったし
僕自身の集中力も
切れちゃったりしてて
まあ、負けちゃったんですけれども
あの大会に居る人達はもう
みんなm...めちゃくちゃ強い人達なんで
その中でも１勝できたっていうのはとても
良かったんじゃないかなと思っております
まあ僕みたいなコミュ障チックな人間にとっては
そもそも楽しいっていうのもあるし
とても大事なコミュニケーションツールに
なっております
非常に悔しいけど！！
これが今の僕..の
実力でござる
まあ、ちょっと最近もーほぼ
ユーチューバーを忘れて
ユ..デュエリストになったんで
ん..ちょっとユ..ユーチューバーに戻ります！
とてもいい経験ができたと思うので
来年に勝とうと思います！
じゃな
♬
【新着ニュース】
《英マンチェスターの爆発事件、ISが犯行声明》
《NHK受信料支払い率 過去最高》
《46年逃走 大坂容疑者を逮捕か》
《北朝鮮 ミサイル発射「成功」》
《キラ容疑で夜神月に逮捕状》
《タイの病院爆発 20人以上負傷》